this is a production of Cornell
University all right welcome to the
afternoon session so we got three talks
on vegetables coming up and so hope you
all had a good lunch it was pretty tasty
I didn't get to eat everything there
like I saw other people eating good
stuff so I will start off talk to myself
about about a couple of the things in
vegetable cover crop systems that have
been of concern that we're trying to get
the most benefit out of cover crops in
these systems so if you're thinking
about vegetable systems what makes them
distinct in terms of cover crops you
have the high revenue so doing good
things can really be worthwhile not
getting a crop off is really expensive
that as a big impact in the most
vegetable systems you're returning very
little organic matter and based on some
work my colleague Jay Mount Pleasant did
based on a sustainable system that was
used in western New York for about 400
years if you're doing no tillage at all
maintaining you know continuous sustain
production you need somewhere in the
neighborhood of 4 or 5 tons of organic
matter returned to the system just to
stay even and vegetable systems aren't
even coming close and intense tillage in
the next the next thing on the list here
so those are those are real challenges
to the system we're cover crops play a
significant role we tend to run very
high fertility that means that the cover
crops grow better they decompose faster
we tend to harvest the crops before
maturity which means that the fertility
and the soil is very high everything is
running full speed and all of a sudden
it stops it's not like most of the field
crops where you're letting the crop
mature and there's this sort of slowing
down period we don't
that in vegetables the other part is
tremendously diverse timing of when
things are planted when things are
harvested and so that means we need a
similar diversity in the kinds of cover
crop opportunities and tools that we
have so I think you know for for field
crops winter ride gets you about 80% of
the way there I think and with vegetable
systems it's maybe 20% so you need a lot
more possibilities and we do some nasty
things so here's harvest nasty yes miss
yeah yeah so the harvesters can be
fairly tough on them here we have some
some demands in terms of the surface of
the soil so the surface of the soil
it's unacceptably lumpy because that's
going to be picking up a lot of bean
sized stones and that don't separate out
well we're getting nice transfer of soil
borne pathogens to the beans they need
to be held up higher so you we have some
unusual requirements this one is solved
by rolling to crush all the nice soil
aggregates we can have a substantial
amount of fall traffic so corn harvester
moves a lot of stuff but that's nothing
compared to 50 tons an acre of cabbage
well I I intend I intend to ignore that
warning yeah doesn't apply to me so if
you're if you're taking off 50 tons per
acre of stuff in the fall when the
ground is wet you're creating some
challenges that can be avoided in some
other crops so yeah so some of the
questions is what what should one do
looking at the Cornell soil health test
which reflects all of these challenges
that you have in the vegetable systems
to try to improve things
the kind of the context of how I've been
thinking about using the cover crops and
doing the outreach in the cover crops
area and so you've seen some things
about the soil health test so I'm not
going to be laboring that today but
basically you get a report back and
there we go and sometimes you get bad
scores that you want to improve matters
on and so we have data on how to improve
some of those and so we can get here
management goals done in terms of the
challenges that are identified by the
soil health tools so these are mostly
done by the different management goal so
producing a decision tool that that's
tailored to the vegetable growers that
has that wide array of choices of cover
crops that will fit the different
windows so this has a bunch of different
times when people might have the
opportunity to plant a cover crop the
durations because sometimes you have a
month or so sometimes you have from kind
of middle of summer not enough season
left to use it but you're not going to
be planting again until spring you can
have quite a lot of time and this goes
so this I put that big in case you wanna
use it it's easy to remember and it
works on your phone so you can use it
anywhere anytime so this is designed so
that you can make decisions fairly
quickly based on constraints of a farm
and so that the different
characteristics of the cover crops are
immediately apparent usually the ones
for deciding which cover crop might fit
and how it fits in the myriad of
combinations that can exist in a
vegetable system so
we have a relatively small number of
answers a relatively large number of
constraints so there's not there's not a
perfect grid to match up everything it's
a lot of judgment calls and we have I
think somewhat some of the ones that are
helpful are unavoidable problems that
there are there are certain things that
you just you can't get around so if this
is if this is an issue on your farm so
here for the red clover retains root rot
and legume
rotations so if you're a bean grower
where root rot is a huge problem there's
no way around that just don't use clover
just cross it right off the list so
that's an example of things where we can
collect information and put it into an
easily applicable tool and then avoid
problems so again picking on the red
clover it's slow to establish so you'll
get a nasty Reedy mess if you just plant
clover the solution is use a nurse crop
so it's a it's a problem that easily
arise if you don't know what you're
doing or you haven't tried it before but
there's a solution to that so those we
have a lot of things that can be added
added in there it's an easy place to
take that this kind of thing is an easy
place to add new information as you do
research and discover new ways to avoid
problems more accurate numbers here
better research support for some of the
management goals but I think that's a
nice tool to bring in the work that many
people do and then I've been putting out
these the fact sheets on the cover crops
and they're designed to contain only in
the information that a vegetable grower
in New York would need so these are
designed specifically to be useful
useless to the Vermont vegetable grower
and that's because it's so specific that
if you're getting information that's
generalized
to apply to a broader area it turns out
not to be useful for a specific farm so
getting that specificity is a real
challenge that we have in serving the
entire grower community and so having no
extraneous information so we're not
learning about Maryland or Vermont we're
just applying to New York that's useful
for the growers so to try to tailor
something that specifically when I
developed these sexy seed sources was
important because people couldn't find
the seeds to buy or they'd be available
for like ten times as much as you would
expect to pay for their commercial
grower so thankfully that's changed it's
relatively easy to find reasonably
priced cover crop seeds these days but
that was something that's also very
local because the transportation costs
are high for a number of those so and
provide a couple of examples of cover
crops where we've done some research to
optimize their use for a particular
location so some of this can be
generalized you'd have to get the some
of the specific timing different in
different locations so we'll start with
buckwheat so it's a very short season
crop the reason it's useful in vegetable
rotations is that it's five weeks you
can have a gap of five weeks between
harvesting one thing and having the
right planting date for another so you
end up with a lot of these odds and ends
of parts of a field that that are
available for very short times and
buckwheat works very well for that so
that's why it's attractive for vegetable
growers it's been used as a weed
suppressor for a long time and our
summer climate is just right for it it's
not too hot not too cold and so we get
some some soil health benefits but it
probably the weeds are the fastest and
so I try to make a point of including
this slide in a lot of talks if you're
gonna have success for the cover crop
this applies to pretty much any cover
crop it has to start fast you have to
have no gaps in the stand and it has to
be killed on time so most growers can
figure out how to make those three
things happen and the answers are
different for every situation but if you
make those three things happen it works
and so with buckwheat you have a fast
SAR so four days Greenline at four days
is what one expects if one is to get
weed suppression so what are the
techniques that will get your green line
in four days not five or six so that's
it's very fast something to think about
how do you how do you do that all the
field preparation timing of when you
plants the kind of planting tools you
use planting depth all the settings you
also need to get by three weeks you need
to have at least 70% ground cover to
suppress the weeds so that's growing
quite quickly and then you need to kill
it on time five weeks buckwheat is very
nice it turns white when it's time to
kill it so it's relatively easy to tell
the difference between not ready and
ready but so that's an example of those
three principles and buckwheat so we
figured out something about the planting
window that gives us this time so this
was done with Northeast Serra funding
explicitly that we looked at different
planting day so we did sequential
plantings through the entire growing
season when we had the opportunity to do
it and of course the weather is
different in different days but so here
is the early growth does it grow fast
enough so here's the 70 the gray line is
70% ground cover and in the springtime
yeah it comes out of the ground but it
really grows too slowly to out-compete
the weeds so you could look and see that
it's there and that it's growing but
really to get enough growth we need to
be into July most of the years and
August is good and then it tails off
pretty quickly and then if you want to
see that the far end of the season so to
get enough biomass out
it really were not talking end of August
anymore like in the previous slide
really it's early August when that
window closes shut so the answer we did
is June and July is when you can plant
buckwheat and have a successful cover
crop in this region so that kind of work
you can develop the greedy models and
get a map of when that last planting
date is for different locations and so
this can inform decision tools and so
this number may not apply to the entire
area that we've mapped here but that the
software is so great at kicking out
information what
so what we've find is that it it's
really pretty varied geographically
throughout that part of the Northeast
here so that's one thing I think in an
earlier session today pointed out how in
developing the Midwest tool you can kind
of figure out these lines run with the
interstates and you've got these nice
broad bands of planting dates and you
come up in the Northeast and it's
nothing like that at all and so trying
to use the same geographic concepts in
making recommendations about planting
dates you really have to change how you
think about it so this kind of mapping
has been helpful for thinking through
that and the climate tools that are
available are really helpful for doing
it so I'm going to talk about crucifer a
little bit that's an another one so
these are a little bit later in the
season than buckwheat but earlier in the
season then the winter grains and
so the ones that we've seen the most of
our is the tillage radish by far but
there's a number of different ones and
you can use them in different ways
depending on how the weather works I
wanted to talk about the planting date
issue specifically here so here we did
trials in a number of so this is
Michigan but the you notice how abruptly
the season ends with these it's like it
goes over a cliff at a particular date
right it's not some subtle slow I think
I can get away with waiting another week
kind of a thing it's when the season is
over the seasons over
and we did this with a number of
different cruciferous that vary in there
cold hardiness so we have things like
the bio drills radish which is super
sensitive all the way up to Athena which
is a winter canola which is fully winter
hardy here and so the question is do the
ones that are more cold hardy can you
plant them later and so if you were to
compare the red radish here with the
green winter canola the two extreme so
how much later can you go with the
canola than the red when the answer is
you can't they all have the same date
that that planting window closes which
was not what I expected to find at all
the plus of this of course is that we
can use the same degree name model for
all of the crucifer so that that saves
an awful lot of research when we want to
develop the corresponding map for
crucifer so here it's a little bit
simpler landscape in the fall than it
was on the buckwheat one that's a warmer
season crop so this is what the four
crucifer does look like this is taken
November third not this year but a few
years ago
they really function differently so you
have Tilney is a white mustard so it's
bolted there it's going the straw is
going to stand through the winter it's
gonna hold snow on the ground throughout
the winter so this is a location where
it's common to have snowfalls one day
melt a couple days later and it snows
again a few days later so holding the
snow in place is a valuable feature we
have a Caliente brown mustard that is
going to have just create a little mat
and not survive the winter at all the
canola is going to live it's going to
look pretty much like that all winter
it's not going to turn brown or anything
and the radish will melt away entirely
fairly quickly but it's a great biomass
producer so that winter behavior is
important so that's an area where
there's still quite a bit to learn how
to use the crucifer x' in just the right
way and so we've had quite a bit of
experience with the radish but we don't
expect the radish to survive at all here
and the goal with these is either said
they should be all dead it should be
completely alive so in between is not
good and it's because they vary in
winter hardiness from variety to variety
you have to match the variety to the
location and you have to vary that or
adjust for the growth stage too so so if
you have really tiny plants if you plant
late and they just come up and you're
you're counting on their growth to come
in the spring time for instance they're
gonna frost teeth it's just with the
freezing and thawing they'll push right
out of the ground but if they're a
little bit bigger so that they now make
a rosette then they're at their maximum
winter hardiness so those are going to
survive so it could be that you're
growing something like canola that makes
a rosette or it could be that you have
some runty plants in the in the planting
that that only came up and made a
rosette where everything else bolted
well those little ones are going to be
surviving and then the the voltage so if
you have a stem or a bulb with like a
radish or a turnip those are going to
freeze the other parts of the plant
are the roots and the leaves they
survive much better through the winter
so if you're trying to carryover
nitrogen for instance those nitrogen
containing parts are going to be
surviving so we're getting that that
match is going to take some tailoring I
think of a fair bit of education
opportunity a fair bit of research
opportunity to find what's going to work
the best so what we found with the
crucifer so it's about a two-week window
it's an artist in New York it moves
around in other places but it's only
about a two-week window so it's fairly
short of course with vegetables a lot of
crucifer vegetables not just the cabbage
that Chris mark showed off that it's
grown quite a lot but the leafy crucifer
czar very popular on vegetable farms
broccoli I predict will be expanding
over the next few years so you can't
have crucifer cover crops and crucifer
cash crops in the same rotation if
they're an important part of your
program the winter killed ones are great
for allowing early access in the spring
and they have tremendous weed
suppression so you end up with
essentially no went cool season weeds in
the springtime if you grow them
differently so that there is residue in
the spring they have the potential to
carryover nitrogen and that's why we
haven't solved how to get that to work
yet as far as I can tell that actually
having the nitrogen still there after
the soil has been saturated in the
springtime is a challenge so it really
needs to be green parts that are going
to decompose after the ground begins to
warm up so it's it's going to be a trick
to get all that recovered but there's a
huge opportunity they take up massive
amounts of nitrogen so for crucifer
crops they support soil borne diseases
but for other crops they're actually
very good at suppressing soil borne
diseases and but they're very particular
and that I think there's probably an
overemphasis on the bio fumigation
concept there's a lot more going on than
that and sometimes there's not that
going on at all I work with some growers
and extension folks in California where
they're their big cash crop is lettuce
and they have a bottom rottenness the
disease their broccoli is a fantastic
suppressor of bottom rot works great
cauliflower useless utterly useless I
think they'd be pretty similar bio a
fumigant mustard you think they'd be
great useless completely useless for
suppressing that disease so no they grow
it lettuce and broccoli solves their
problem but so how do we use the
crucifer effectively targeted for the
specific diseases and finding the
varieties and types that will actually
do a very good job for us there so so
here's an experiment where we tried to
really identify the effects on a number
of different soil health parameters and
what aggregate stability is the one I'm
going to show you but the story was the
same for all of them so we wanted to
show in the vegetable hi tillage low
organic matter return system what would
these different cover crops do for the
soil health parameters and we knew that
we couldn't detect anything over a
one-year period so we used the same
cover crop four years in a row on these
plots we had different vegetables each
year so the wrote vegetables rotated but
the cover crop was the same so you
wouldn't necessarily want to do that on
the farm but we wanted to do that to
really try to push the effect of that
and pick up what the different ones did
and so we had midsummer ones and then
later summer ones and so here's ones
that would be used in midsummer so
annual ryegrass buckwheat Sudan grass
yellow mustard and the control is
leaving it
during the non cropping part of the
season we had a couple of different
fields and so what you want to compare
is how much did the wet aggregate
stability improve after four years
relative to the bare ground and the
answer is you didn't see it move yet and
so then if you look at the winter ones
or the late summer planted one so annual
ryegrass ryan tree to Cayley you have
live roots all winter long until the
springtime so you might expect a larger
effect from those than from radish
turnip and mustard that died but again
you compare after four years of these
cover crops relative to the bare ground
we're gonna have to make those error
bars a whole lot smaller we're going to
detect anything right so the effect is
small so we've got this high tillage
system that we're really beating up the
wet aggregate stability with all the
other operations we do so in this case
taking that system and only adding the
cover crop is not enough to move the
needle and I think that's something that
we're going to see in these intensely
managed systems that it takes a lot more
integration of different management
practices if we're going to move the
needle on some of the soil health
parameters
so intense tillage very hard to
counteract if with just cover crops it
takes more than that so reducing tillage
is important I think of the soil health
test is being a good way to identify
constraints you may not be able to make
those constraints go away at all or just
using cover crops so some of them you
just have to learn to deal with that as
an issue on that particular farm or
field that that's going to be a
limitation and so avoiding having it get
worse may be the best that can be done
for some of those so the changing the
management they those many of those
measured parameters changed quite slowly
so where people are accustomed to doing
a soil test for the chemical nutrients
and you add more and then you see next
year that those numbers have gone up
that works fine for chemicals for soil
health parameters they're likely to move
more slowly so not not getting antsy
worrying oh I I did this treatment in
that treatment and this year I did my
soil health test and it didn't change in
the way I expected it to well we will
hear that yeah so giving the limitations
continued attention and cover crops is
part of that story it has to be part of
a larger context of how the vegetables
are grown so that's my last slide so
thanks very much yeah
[Applause]
come on glass slide so what looking
forward what do you think village right
yes we're doing it but not sure is
I know intuitively it's a good thing but
much danger I'm curious if any work on
eternal investment to buy it right so
yeah reducing the tillage I think that's
that's an area where we're we the
community not me my lab are looking very
much and and for cover crops that that
help you reduce tillage so you the cover
crop is doing some of the things that
the tillage tools did and think of the
cover crops in that ways so with with
the zone tiller system you could combine
that with where you plant something like
the radish in the planting row so that
that will work up much more easily and
then of us winter hardy cover crop in
between the roads so so strip tilling is
a an opportunity I think the our GPS
guidance has enormous potential to allow
tillage only of the area you need for a
lot of our crops we need the the good
seed bed needs to be about like that
right that'll do it and if you have
porous soil elsewhere you don't need to
actually till that so that's what we
need but we're actually doing this much
for each row that's that's overkill size
I see some opportunities there and the
growers who are doing that continually
year after year finding easier access to
the field for harvest and planting
a whole bunch of other good soil health
benefits derived from that that really
pale
yeah
[Music]
yeah
yeah we did a lot of that too there
there is about a one week or so window
and it seems to work but it's different
by that window will fall somewhere in
about a six week window but you don't
know in advance which one it's going to
be and I don't like that kind of tools
so are the the publication isn't out yet
but the answer is going to be this is
probably not going to work out very well
yeah so the I've done most of my work on
this in Geneva some and if it got in
Michigan in Geneva there is a lot of
cabbage productions so we had really
intense free beetle pressure in the fall
it hasn't been an issue at all in with
overwintering crucifer x' they they
flower in April and early May and so the
flea beetles are not out yet so with
both of those we've avoided the flea
beetle season but that's come come June
they'll be foliate the entire plant
right right right
right yeah yeah my time so yeah it yeah
it depends on the timing of the flea
beetle populations in those locations I
think in a lot of locations the flea
beetles will be pretty much finished off
by the time the radishes are really
growing all right thanks this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu